it was the Irish playwright Oscar Wilde
who famously wrote we are all in the
gutter but some of us are looking at the
Stars that phrase may feel truer now
than ever as people in lockdowns
worldwide are rediscovering the joys of
stargazing from London Roxana Saberi
shows us how society shutting down has
brought the night sky to life around the
world cities that never sleep are
slowing down under lock downs and the
air we breathe is clearing up from the
streets to the skies I can just see some
craters to the the southern part of the
moon you can see that very very clearly
for decades the universe has captivated
Trevor Pitts but he had trouble
capturing it from his home in southern
England because so many planes lit up
the night sky like this and now there
aren't any airplanes in the picture that
must be pretty exciting as a stargazer
yeah
actually almost become a vampire because
I spent with global travel grinding to a
halt and people staying home to stop the
spread of the deadly coronavirus layers
of smog are lifting revealing sparkling
skies these satellite images taken
before and after coronavirus lockdowns
showed just how dramatic the drop in air
pollution has been in Europe and in
China but it's not just cleaner air
making stargazing easier there's also
less light coming from shops factories
and stadiums forced to shut down with
many of us under orders to stay indoors
stargazers say we now have a unique
opportunity to enjoy the clearest night
skies in decades even in big cities like
here in London
all we have to do look up lots of people
think that you need very expensive
equipment that you need a very high-end
telescope you absolutely do not all you
need is your eyes and an app like this
can help you pick out the planets and
constellations since the UK's lockdown
began people across the country have
reached out to the ghost stargazing
group and its co-founder Neil Sanders
they're sharing glimpses of the sky and
moments of joy for Trevor Pitt embracing
the wonders of the universe Wow it is
gorgeous provide some perspective that
we need in times like these the three
months of the lockdown there's a long
time but it's not forever I'm still
there the stars are still there
taking them in can also help us feel
connected wherever you are you can
always call someone very unifying thing
that can bring everybody together and
that may be more important now than ever
for CBS this morning Saturday Roxana
Saberi London and that is pretty cool to
think about we had a super moon this
past week another one coming up on May
7th and those stargazing apps are
fantastic